bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui est une journée
exceptionnelle figurez vous que j'ai
exposé pour la première fois ma
merveilleuse collection de feuilles
mortes dans la galerie de l'île aux
enfants
bon jeu julie à vos fans vous habitez
julie mon exposition est prête elle
n'attend plus que vous ah excusez moi
mais vraiment c'est impossible que je
vienne de 4 en fin de semaine prochaine
j'ai vraiment trop travail fassent
eux-mêmes prochaine mon lit mais mais
c'est horriblement loin françois
françois je vous attends pour le
vernissage de ma merveilleuse exposition
de feuilles mortes
nouvelle chute est ce serait vraiment
été un grand plaisir mais je travaille
encore à londres dont messi messi écoute
et regarde ggg tous mes balles non il
faut que je m'en occupe il faut que je
que je prépare des jeux pour les enfants
il faut que je veux que tu dis et puis
vous savez entre nous mais nous elle
chutait des feuilles mortes l'année
dernière à l'automne j'en ai balayé par
milliers c'est magique on assistait pas
en casimir en optyl affaires en sucre en
toi moi qui va venir à mon vernissage à
quoi un manga ni sage oui c'est lenoir
peu savant que l'on donne à la réception
d'une exposition mais est-ce qu'il y
aura des bonnes choses à manger comme
anvers message de monsieur du snj au
plus tôt non non non non non tu sais
c'est l'exposition de toute ma
collection magnifique de feuilles mortes
non non non non non non je je je je
connais déjà beau votre collection de
feuilles morue avait obligé à l'avoir
dit fois on les récents mois mais cela
n'empêche pas devenir un mauvais message
kazemi non non je ne veux pas aux dons
en plus qu'à avoir pris vernissage il
n'y aura même pas de bonnes choses à
manger alors un ne comptez pas sur moi
rhin non
il faut que je trouve une solution aux
îles campagne wimille est-ce que vous
pouvez m'envoyer un télégramme à part
dont les voûtes et souverain non
mademoiselle vite et je ne suis pas
sourd et je vous prierais de ne pas
insulter un employé des ptt dans
l'exercice de ses fonctions en mai mais
je ne vous insulte pas non mais je
voulais simplement vous demander si vous
pouviez m'envoyer des télégrammes des
montagnes de télégrammes oisel futé je
ne suis pas fait pour apporter des
télégrammes ni pour les amboisiens je
suis très pour apporter le courrier il
ya la poste mobile aux enfants pour cela
qu'hier j'ai compris gillett s'est pas
tout à coup ci c'est pourquoi c'est
impossible pourquoi parce que la poste
est fermé à cette heure ci
laquelle malchance bardot
décidément factor vous êtes vraiment
sourd
moiselle futé je vous en prie je vous en
prie moment je réfléchis je l'admets pas
les insultes non mais mais ne vous
fâchez pas petit facteur bourgault non
le grand compositeur beethoven était
sort également oui oui oui seulement lui
quand on lui disait j'ai entendait pas
là là mais qu'est ce que je vais faire
il faut pourtant que je trouve une
solution
réfléchi
france soir mais julie tu ne fais pas un
jeu pour les enfants écoutent julie g
mabille beaucoup faire un jeu mais
vraiment j'ai trop toute chose à faire
j'ai encore une quinzaine de ballons à
gonfler j'ai jemma commanda rédige
également un livre très intéressant a
fini en événements
vraiment je m'en sors pas ralala moi
aussi j'ai beaucoup de travail mais en
fait nous sommes là pour les enfants
c'est pouvons pas les abandonner
jeudi j'ai une idée une idée si tu te
faisais toi ce jeu non et oui écoute
pour une fois ça l'échangerais ça leur
ferait plaisir
beaucoup de françois tu sais bien je ne
suis pas du tout capable quand je pose
une devinette je donne ma réponse avant
maintenant j'ai beaucoup trop modeste
coutu françois ça me gêne beaucoup moi
tu toi tu le fais beaucoup mieux que moi
mais c'est pas gentil du poème lowell le
rendent ce petit service et compte
cependant le chose bon bah écoute si
c'est pas possible de faire autrement
tant pis mais alors je ne te garantit
pas le résultat bon courage je te laisse
trop gentil
les enfants venaient les cvo et venez
avec moi
une traque nous allons faire un jeu
formidable regardez ce que j'ai trouvé
ce film était mieux ne laissait pas
comme ça mon vieux ray mais enfin mais
c'est très important
vous savez ce qui s'est passé j'étais
sur la plage avec mes amis les crabes
lorsque soudain dire que vous savez le
crav américains d'être passage dans la
rue le disque s'est mis à crier il
venait de recevoir cette bouteille sur
la tête que dans l'ariège et j'espère
qu'ils ne s'est pas fait trop mal non je
veux faire un pansement ça va mais
regardez on dirait qu'il ya quelque
chose n'était d'ailleurs de la bouteille
c'est peut-être un médecin belge mais
oui mais c'est pour ça que je suis venu
enfin je ne vous aurais jamais dérangé
un show vous écoutez nous allons savoir
rapidement il souffre il suffit de
l'ouvrir dépêche-toi françois j'ai hâte
de savoir
julie tu un tire bouchon de tire bouchon
oui oui c'est un bon bouche à
un tour de chant où j'ai pu blesser
son prochain
je ne trouve pas résignés on nous
annonce il ya peut-être quelques en
danger ça y est je les prêter
et 12
à l'ofac terme en tire-bouchon
l'embauchant et william ait choisi les
tire-bouchons facteurs que je vous ai
prêté la semaine dernière
chez fact hc en supplie rapporté le new
deal vous et les bouchons oui on prend
prenez votre vélo merci à tout de suite
ici c'était un trésor caché quelque part
oh oui oui j'ai cherché comment cela oui
un jour j'ai eu dans un livre que des
pirates avaient trouvé une bouteille
dans laquelle il y avait un parchemin
indiquant l'emplacement d'un trésor mais
il ya quelque chose que je ne comprends
pas françois weigel
comment a fait cette bouteille pour ne
pas se noyer
casimir c'est cette bouteille ne pouvait
pas coulé puisqu'il y avait un bouchon
qui empêche l'eau de mer de rentrer
dedans comme lé plein d'air bien elle
flottait à la flotte et sur la flotte au
mazel fuite a annoncé le 8 mai mais
c'est vrai que vous avez voté une telle
situation elle allait
mais il faut mettre en maillot de bain
dans ce que l'on vous baigner dans la
mer mademoiselle foutait
figurez-vous que j'étais en train de me
promener en barque au large de la bd
casini lui quand tout à coup je me suis
aperçu que j'avais les pieds trempés
et c'est alors que j'ai vu est venu spa
non farceur en train de percer la coque
toman
j'ai coulé elle a fallu que je revienne
à la nage
écoutez c'est très dangereux de
s'aventurer aussi loin tout seul
ça a dû vous vous muscler les bras ça
vous aidera à soulever vos feuilles
mortes
[Musique]
comme ça que
mes amis mais voici revoici avec le
turbo chaud nous allons pouvoir enfin
ouvrir dans cette bouteille à sa
bouteille mais vous l'avez vous trouvée
nez dans l'année c'est casimir qui nous
l'a rapporté et il y a deux dans un
message
ses traits à bolide dernière le courrier
d autres poursuivants mademoiselle futé
mais dans le cas présent communiqué ni
le nom ni l'adresse du destinataire
c'est le premier qui trouve la bouteille
qui a le droit de lire le message est
con et je vais vous le dire à vous mes
chers amis les gens intelligents qui
aimait la nature et les feuilles mortes
je vous demande de venir au plus vite me
rejoindre dans l'île aux enfants car
l'événement le plus exceptionnel de ce
siècle vient de s'y produire et côté
l'exposition de ma collection complète
de feuilles mortes c'est pas fini je ne
trouve personne là c'est intelligent
dans l'île aux enfants pour l'admirer
essais signés est méritée